[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
happy
wednesday right it's wednesday
so about that steering wheel story
it was a bombshell all right minus the
shell part
just like all those other anti-trump
bombshells
at the jan 6 hearing yesterday a star
witness no one ever heard of testified
about something she didn't see
which right there makes her testimony as
legitimate as smoke signals from liz
warren
so what's it just that is then president
donald trump was being driven back to
the white house after the january 6
rally he demanded the car pull over so
he could snack on an injured dog on the
side of the road
yeah it was a pekingese which he then
slathered in ketchup
and devoured with his bare bloody hands
donald jr was laughing in the back seat
yeah well she was told that anyway
actually she was told that on the way to
the rally donald trump stripped naked
declared himself the king of siam and
then proceeded to randomly type out all
of shakespeare's plays on a smith corona
word processor he borrowed from his good
friend and mentor adolf hitler who isn't
really dead but lives in a shampoo
bottle in mar-a-lago pool houses
yeah maybe that's a bit much but her
claims are even less believable she
claims she was told that trump actually
tried to grab the steering wheel from a
secret service agent
the verb used lunge he lunged
yes lunch the thing my personal trainer
makes me do
by holding my daiquiri out of arm's
reach
about eight inches
but yeah trump apparently crawled out
through the back window of the beast
the beast which is the code name for the
presidential limo as well as hillary
clinton
oh my god
shuffled across the roof then slid down
in through the driver's side window to
grab the wheel while screaming screw the
guns let jesus take the wheel
sounds real right
good thing we have a republican there to
keep it all on the up and up
i kid but it's odd how liz cheney has
become the vindictive ex-wife that
donald trump never knew he had
she's now a screech owl with a fake
serenity of a stepford wife
guys don't remember the stepford wives
anyway so the people who spent four
years telling you trump was so out of
shape he that he had one foot in the
grave and the other on a packet of mayo
now i want you to believe you can
slither around a moving vehicle like
he's jackie chan
still the press inhaled the hearsay like
it was parfait
the president's in real trouble not
least for assaulting his secret service
agent this is where i confess that i
cannot recall ever having heard another
example of a president trying to
physically
hijack his own motorcade to grab the
steering wheel and i mean his dangerous
dangerous act and then
whatever to grab the secret service
agent i mean this this is
beyond that trump was the wrong man for
the job that's going to stick for a lot
of people you know the president of the
united states you know attacking a
secret service agent
attacking the media hasn't been this
excited about an attack
since
you know who
[Laughter]
jesse you're back
of course like samolet's stinky tail
just wait it out the story comes apart
like a cheese steak dropped in a hot tub
i told him it was a cheesesteak
oh my god oh gosh
sorry governor yeah sorry
first our very own david spunt which is
the past tense of spant
confirms that on background both men
implicated in this anecdote dispute the
lunge and it's not just us nbc's peter
alexander also says a source close to
the secret service says both bobby engel
the lead agent and the driver are
prepared to testify under oath that
neither man was assaulted and that mr
trump never lunged for the wheel then
there's abc's john santucci sources tell
him the secret service will push back
against any allegation of an assault or
trump reaching for the wheel nor did he
suddenly grow eight foot rubber arms
like he was in the fantastic four
finally cnn admits yes
an official denied saying an agent told
hutchinson this story yeah even cnn
i mean when you lose cnn you know you
lose
cnn
and its remaining 12 viewers
actually it's one viewer but it goes by
the pronoun they
[Laughter]
there's
there's more disputes over what
hutchinson claims something about a note
she says she wrote but didn't maybe i
don't know we could go into it but we'd
get a more believable driving story from
paul pelosi
it's all cloaked in over rot theater and
not even good theater like you see on
broadway but community theater like a
play your aunt margaret has the lead in
margaret which is why the hearing's a
joke it was a one-sided charade that
undermines everything presented it's why
no one watches it unless it's force fed
to them by the media they thought a
heavily produced special created by an
abc producer with surprise cameos
featuring people you never heard of
would blow your minds but it failed like
a remake of the love boat
even testimony from charo can't save
them
i'm old
honestly how much of this guy do you
need to see
you know if i were cynical i'd say he's
a useful idiot a glutton for strange new
respect from his temporary liberal pals
he always looks like he's about to burst
into tears
what does kinziger mean in german anyway
karen
[Laughter]
you know he should save that face when
he gets a job driving lynn cheney to
msnbc
yeah poor liz
a fatal attraction level stalker who
just can't get over president trump
which reminds me donald hide the bunny
these references they're so old
i get them though and that's all that
matters fact is the commit committee
thought this was a slam dunk a show
trial full of second-hand accounts who
would complain the media now they're
lapping it up like it's aoc's bathwater
watching it reminded me of that game we
played as kids where you sat in a circle
and whispered something to the person
next to you until it went all the way
around the circle and by the end it was
totally different than what was
whispered at the start
i think it was called spin the bottle
but that's what hearsay is and i'm not
even saying it's false
why bother when the committee is false
in the truest sense of the word it's the
big red bow on the box of corruption
brought to you by the same clowns that
created hoaxes for six years
it prepped hearsay steeped in heavily
produced propaganda seriously i keep
waiting to hear a director yell cut
let's do that again with a little more
feeling adam
and it's designed not to uncover truth
but to distract you from the real truth
of crime inflation immigration all the
things this administration fails us on
on a massive scale but we see through it
like a condom stretched over a
flashlight
i don't know how i know
fact is we know trump we know trump has
a temper i still remember the wedgie he
gave me after i replaced his diet coke
with pepsi
i've never been lifted that high in my
life
i was so happy
fact is they created a show trial but
forgot to bring the show
and now their honesty is on trial to
which i say lock them up
let's
welcome
tonight's guests
she's so patriotic mount rushmore takes
field trips to see her every summer
south dakota governor and author of the
new book not my first rodeo
chrissy dome
she talks so fast she makes sign
language interpreters call in sick
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
his jokes have him laughing all the way
to the bank
the food bank
actor writer and comedian jamie lissau
and she brings out the best in people
when they report her to law enforcement
fox news contributor cat tim
they're pretty weak today
congratulations on your great new book
governor gnome i love the fact that
surprises surprises you have an american
flag on soccer right i know i know
anyway and you're on a horse yes did you
review it on amazon yet not yet but
apparently that really matters it does
matter i'll get i'll be i'll do that
tonight that'd be great i'll do that
tonight and i won't even read it first
kidding so about these hearings um have
you been tuning in or what do you think
of them
i have been tuning in as little as
possible i've been paying attention but
i i can't only honestly focus on it i
mean how can you we're literally making
stuff up now i think i heard a rumor in
the hallway outside the girls bathroom
that maybe this happened you know eight
nine ten months ago but i'm not sure
yeah exactly yes do you swear under oath
yes i swear under oath that's what
happened
it's literally what we're doing in
washington dc now i think this
government has fallen to the lowest
level i could have imagined you know
what kills me about this too is that
okay this is not over yet it's
open-ended
a it's open-ended and b who's paying for
it we are oh so there's actually you're
not paying for this greg who's paying
for it your your children oh
grandchildren oh remember we've been
saying that for a long time it's not you
screw you not with those shoes
i win again
i win again always winning you're so
tired of winning i'm tired i'm tired of
winning no think about it the reason why
this doesn't end is because we're
footing the bill i know i know it's
insane jamie are people watching this in
alaska they have televisions am i right
yeah i mean we don't have cable but we
do have television
this cnn thing my goodness their their
viewership is they're going to start
calling it nothing anyone wants to see
nn
[Laughter]
by the way talk about the secret service
for being the secret service i felt like
there was a lot of names and a lot of
facts they just put out there they're
gonna have to start calling it the can't
keep a secret service
um very true i got really worried well
not worried but i was thinking about
wouldn't it be crazy to have secret
service like following you everywhere
just how crazy that would be and by the
way just exagger like you said say it is
true that he reach for the wheel he's
not a terrorist yeah he's not attacking
anyone i think biden was jealous he was
like oh man i just have a little toy
wheel in the back
but i'm just glad no one follows me
around because i just feel like wow
remember that show cheaters yes i just
feel like if you remember that one i
feel like if they followed me they you
know the people be like telling my
ex-wife they'd be like oh we think he's
cheating on you we thought he was
cheating on you he ordered two dinners
from chirping chicken and then they
would bust into my room and it would
just be me eating both of them yes
and they'd be like the good news is your
husband's not cheating on you the bad
news is he's a slob
interesting and sad tale
we're there for you yes we've got your
back when the governor says that
i think she's lying by the way
i'm a really good listener
all right emily you're a lawyer or so
you claim um
what is lacking in this committee this
hearing
substantive due process i mean i i will
say this is all about home field
advantage right this is just like a
grand jury proceeding where it's all
about the prosecution there's no hearsay
rules there's no objections there's no
cross-examination there's no evidence
code whatsoever and that is why
grand juries lead to a 99.9
indictment rate and the other difference
is that grand jury proceedings are
secret usually whereas this is being
played out on national television um and
to me the credibility issue here is the
fact that these guys are holding
themselves out to be the ultimate fact
finders these are the investigators
right when in grand jury proceedings the
whole point is that that kicks off or is
one of the first steps of the criminal
justice proceedings right they go then
to trial they go then to bring charges
but here obviously there would be a
referral but they are holding themselves
out as the ultimate court and for sure
in the court of public opinion that
seems to be what they care about the
most
in an election year yes
and that's the whole point this thing
could go but the thing i keep going back
to the fact that there's
there's no disincentive to stop
with this is if if they can they're not
even doing their job they're we're
paying for their campaign ads this is
this is an entire campaign ad it's crazy
cat absolutely crazy will you ever make
up stories about me
i don't think i have to
fair enough uh but no this was popping
up on my phone last night and i didn't
even click on it right which is wild
yeah because like i love
tea you know and this sounds like this
would be some crazy tea yeah but i'm
just what do you mean by tea like you
know whatever i can't make you younger
so i don't know
i know what it means i just like the
phrase uh but it reminds me i actually
had a friend
used to be my friend he told the best
stories until i kept catching him lying
and i just lost interest he said to me
he was like you never asked me anything
about my life i'm like yeah because i
never know what you're telling about
your life is actually your life and i
actually regret listening so intently to
that story you told me about you and
harry styles in a hot tub which he did
tell me don't think it was true
uh and i like i'm there to be a friend
but i don't want to be like you know
like
the test audience for your erotic fan
fiction
but it's the same it's the same yes
uh
it's the same sort of thing here where
it's like how many times can things turn
out to be that's you know sound really
you know explosive that turn out to be
not true or overblown for people just
check out because i know that i kind of
have hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else